we have a great panel today to discuss
Ukraine past and present I can't think
of a better group to discuss this today
well before we begin with with some
questions at all that I'll moderate I'll
introduce the full panel as you know we
have ambassador John Herbst John's the
director of the Eurasia Center here at
the Atlantic Council he's also the
former US ambassador to Ukraine next we
have Nadia McConnell Nadia is the
president of the US Ukraine foundation
to her left is Naphtali Rifkin Naphtali
is a research fellow at the victims of
communism Memorial Foundation and last
but not least we have Michael sab Q
Michaels a director of the Ukraine
national information service which is
part of the Ukrainian Congress Committee
of America he's also the chair of the US
whole lot America committee and Michael
if you don't mind I'll start with you
and then we'll work our way back very
little is known to the outside world and
even in Eastern Europe of the events of
Holodomor can you can you talk about
this this lack of information and lack
of understanding specifically what many
would be just would describe as the
Soviet disinformation campaign which
during 1932 and 1933 and really since
then great absolutely thank you
first I would like to thank the Atlanta
Council for hosting this event it is not
every day that we get a group together
such as this of experts and of of
audience participants that can talk
about the Holdem or the hold water is
one of the least known atrocities in the
world frankly speaking we from the
Ukrainian American community call it a
genocide and we call it a genocide
because even the person that termed the
coin genocide Raphael Lemkin
a Ukrainian at the United Nations had
used the whole de Moura as an example of
what true genocide is I look at this and
I look at this in the perspective of
what happens nearly 85 years ago in
Ukraine and frankly speaking what is
happening right now the two are parallel
but looking at it that's
you are quite similar as well and I'd
like to begin with a quote a quote from
a French writer an aristocrat when the
mid-1800s used to travel quite often to
Russia and had an opportunity to meet
the Czar's
various czars had opportunity to meet
various noble men and also into the he
went into the countryside and in his
book which is letters from Russia
French writer Marquis de Castilla quotes
a Russian civil servant proudly
proclaiming the following and I quote
Russia wise denies the facts makes war
on the evidence and wins that I think is
the perspective of what we're doing with
right now
whether this book letters from Russia
written nearly 175 years ago the
Holodomor which happened 85 years ago
and the incidents that are happening
right now in eastern Ukraine and Crimea
shows that Russia arise and Russia makes
war on the facts now this is not
necessarily a historical lesson that I'd
like to give you today what I'd like to
give you as a philosophical notion of
what is happening in that area and what
is emanating from Moscow from Moscow
it's not so much a territorial grab of
Ukraine whether was during Soviet Union
times of the 1920s
or even right now in the in the early
2000s what it is it's it's an
informational war it's a traction as to
what you can get out there for the
people to believe and at the same time
do as much of the unfortunate to various
societies as possible so it's a it's a
matter of principle it's a matter of
democratic principles versus it's a
matter of authoritarianism dictatorship
and how you wield power now it's it's
it's quite interesting that the Soviets
denied the holding water for the longest
of times frankly speaking they denied it
to about
mid-1980s when we in the greater
ukrainian diaspora whether in the united
states or throughout the world started
speaking more and more about it and
there was some resonance associated with
it there was some traction associated
with it members of congress presidents
of the united states issued their
particular statements about the
Holodomor frankly speaking it culminated
in 2008 with a statement by president
george w bush that said that the
Holodomor was a quote crime against
humanity
so the soviets having denied it for so
long and only after a lot of the
information started trickling out after
the dissolution of the Soviet Union in
1991 did they even acknowledge that the
Holdem what happened it's the same thing
fast-forward 85 years later gentlemen
fast forward 85 years from the Holodomor
to what is happening right now in
eastern Ukraine and Crimea if you were a
member of March of 2014 nearly three
years to the date that the Russians
started invading Crimea with
quote-unquote little green men that
Putin obviously said there is no such
thing as little green men in Ukraine
that obviously had had no notion that
this was being done in an organized
fashion in terms of the illegal
annexation of the autonomous Republic of
Crimea in the Ukraine in Ukraine so this
is the the the the the point of the
story and what we see is not so much
about how history repeats itself because
unfortunately it does repeat itself but
how we have to tackle those historical
burdens of not being silent I had a
wonderful opportunity to see a premiere
of the film last week bitter harvest
which you just saw a just a very short
trailer the movie is poignant the movie
is riveting the mood movie in captures
your heart and your soul because it is
about a love story in the dire
circumstances of a forced famine in
Ukraine but I picked up one amazing
quote from that particular movie and the
quotes came from a Soviet Commerce
are saying that reality is the enemy if
reality is the enemy how do we fight
against who is the enemy is reality the
true enemy or obviously is the
disinformation that is being strewn
about the enemy and this is what I'd
like to leave you I'd like to leave you
with certain instances of what are
happening in today's world unfortunately
there are a lot is happening a lot of a
lot is being said in terms of fake news
a lot of being said in terms of facts
how to look at these particular facts
the facts are there ladies and gentlemen
the facts have always been there
eighty-five years ago the facts were
there nearly 175 years ago when the
French writer and aristocrat traveled
throughout Russia the facts are all
there in 1932-33 there were journalists
that actually were embedded in Ukraine
that did get out the story it is
unfortunate that a lot of their writing
did not receive the prominence of one
particular writer for the New York Times
the name of which Walter durante has a
pure surprise within the New York Times
building these are all the attributes
what we have to deal with in today's
world but in today's world since we know
a lot of the facts we we know a lot of
the information that is already strewn
about it is our opportunity now to make
sure that that doesn't repeat itself
it's not about the history the history
is necessary it's about the perception
and the perception that is being made
unfortunately from Russia whether it was
Sarris Russia whether was the Soviet
Union in communist Russia or whether it
is today's Russian Federation it's that
perception of what is reality and in the
movie if reality is the enemy then that
is what we have to deal with but how do
you combat that how do you combat this
this information that is happening
there are many ways first and foremost
if the example of mh17 in july of 2014
the facts are out there more needs to be
done more investigations more trials
frankly speaking have to be brought
other instances in terms of combating
this the disinformation is the movie
itself the movie itself combats all
types of disinformation stemming from
Moscow the Holodomor Memorial which we
dedicated in November of 2015
prominent location in Washington DC in
the corner of Massachusetts Avenue and
North Capitol Street where as the tip
you can see the US Capitol it's very
important to have these types of
instances curriculum within our high
school social studies programs I went
through the high school systems here in
the United States and frankly speaking
if I as a Ukrainian American didn't
raise the issues of the Holodomor
unfortunately I don't think much would
have been said and I have any even have
an example in my college my college
courses of Russian history from the mid
1800s to the mid 1900s going from Tsar's
Russia to to communist Russia or the
Soviet Union and talking about Lenin and
Stalin five-year plans
whereas collectivization was mentioned
but not necessarily in the capacity of
what it meant for the starving of nearly
five seven 10 million people in Ukraine
this is what we need to do we need to
bring forth the facts we need to make
sure that this is evident and as I would
mention earlier one of the greatest
examples of Holdem or in terms of its
the bunking of the information from the
Russian Federation is recognizing it as
its true genocide I leave you with one
particular quote as well and this is a
quote from Desmond Tutu this is a quote
about what should inspire us to work in
the future and to debunk of out of this
misinformation and a lot of this
propaganda it is a quote as follows
if you are neutral in situations of
injustice you have chosen the side of
the oppressor and I think those are
poignant words that we need to remember
as we examine a little bit more of the
Holodomor in this panel discussion and
if you have the unique opportunity of
watching the film bitter harvest thank
you thank you
Naftali following up with what Michael
talked about you've done a lot of
research regarding how reporters and
politicians misrepresented the events in
the early 1930s can you talk about this
a little bit more and in how this
misrepresentation of the facts affected
past events but also what's going on
currently in Ukraine and also how that
affects the culture of the society
uh-huh sure first of all thank you Tim
and and Michael and I apologize to the
room I picked the worst day to get a
cold so I don't know how it's going to
sound my voice coming through the mic I
wanted to pick up on something Michael
just said about high school curricula
and it's important to note that the way
we talk about history the way the words
that we use here in Ukraine and in
Russia have an impact on younger
generations I was sifting through some
Russian high school textbooks and I
found an example of how Russian children
are taught about low basic history like
the famine in Ukraine 1932-33 so this is
a quote from a textbook published in
Russia in 2008 the author by the name of
Danilov it says the famine was a result
of weather conditions as well as the
incompleteness of collectivization
processes in parentheses collective
farms were not yet able to provide the
required level of production of bread
while the kulaks the wealthy farmers
were liquidated as a social class and
did not participate in the production
so the
this is just to substantiate your point
further that the disinformation has an
impact in the way we educate our
children here and in Russia and I also
wanted to pick up on something you
mentioned about Walter durante how many
people here know who altered Durante is
I think a sizable portion room for those
of you who don't know who he is
he was the New York Times correspondent
in Moscow from 1917 to I believe he was
the bureau chief until 34 and then 34 35
and then he stayed on as a reporter and
he won a Pulitzer for a series of 11
articles partially covering the holiday
more in Ukraine and for those of you who
don't think he deserves a Pulitzer which
I do not you may change your mind
because he may deserve a Pulitzer for
the Orwellian linguistic gymnastics in
his article he writes simply there is no
actual starvation but there is
widespread mortality from diseases due
to malnutrition
now Durante is an easy target and we
could as many do dismiss him as a liar
but Durante unfortunately was not an
outlier at the time famous people
intelligent people like George Bernard
Shaw HG Wells French prime minister
Edouard Aereo were all fooled by
Russia's propaganda campaign during the
Holodomor even Arthur Kessler mmm that's
the cold even Arthur Kessler author of
darkness at noon which i think is one of
the best books on communism ever written
unfortunately dismissed the dying
Ukrainians as quote enemies of the
people who preferred begging to work so
my question is why why the shameless
lying that the almost hilarious
doublespeak the complete denial of
reality who do these people think
they're fooling
as always George Orwell holds the key to
the mind that can believe
miss slavery and ignorance is strength
in 1945 Orwell wrote it was considered
equally proper to publicize famines when
they happened in India and to conceal
them when they happened in the Ukraine
and if this was true before the war the
intellectual atmosphere is certainly no
better now and I think now extends to
2017 Orwell gets to the heart of the
matter it's not that the holida more
deniers were fools although many of them
were fooled by Russia's disinformation
campaign which for example removed
starving orphans from the street before
the arrival of the French prime minister
it's that it is fashionable in this long
twentieth century of Ukrainian history
from the holiday more to the war in
Donbass to create false equivalence
between the common tragedies of the
human condition and the deliberate
systematic and malicious aggression of
the Russian regime I want to share with
you a quote from another journalist a
good guy this time Gareth Jones was the
journalist who originally broke the
story of the holiday more he interviewed
Soviet foreign minister Maxime deunov in
1933 and in that interview it be enough
took a line that we have heard from many
Russian foreign ministers since he said
flat-out well there is no famine which
of course is a blatant lie but then he
tailored and amended his statement a
little bit he said you must take a
longer view the present hunger is
temporary in writing books you must have
a longer view it would be difficult to
describe it as hunger I noticed the
sentence construction there are no
active verbs my college English
professor would be appalled he always
used to ask me who is doing what to whom
hunger and famine occur all over the
world all the time in India for example
like Orwell said and it depend of his
trying to say that the famine in Ukraine
which he says was really a famine just
occurred without any cause or any effect
necessarily similarly over the past week
or so Russian officials have been asking
Ukraine to reconsider its economic
sanctions on dun bus and quote stop the
attack
done bus as if the conflict in done bus
simply occurred in a vacuum the Russian
regime and many people who don't know
better talk about the holida more as one
famine amongst many in a year that
killed millions of people
similarly rushed the Russian regime and
others who don't know better talk about
done bus as a semi-frozen conflict that
seems to be symptomatic of 2017 nobody's
at fault they seem to say nobody's
getting hurt they seem to believe that's
just the way the world is these days
they want us to think it's the so-called
long view that Serbian Foreign Minister
need to be enough wanted us to take
thank you not dia we've it seems like
there's there's a pattern here it sort
of a struggle for the truth and yeah can
you talk about why this is and are there
similarities between the 1930s and today
well definitely I guess I'd like to
divide my remarks into two parts looking
back what happened then and actually
looking at various issues regarding
Ukraine be it turn Obul the millennia of
Christianity or the warned are there
there are just parallels that are just
so striking first I want to talk about
the parallels here in the United States
as Michael said the first official
recognition of the famine occurred in
the mid 80s we began to to commemorate
the 50th anniversary of the famine so
first there were resolutions to
commemorate the famine and then there
was the resolution to have the
Commission the United States was the
first government in the world to
officially recognize that the that the
famine to hold the motor took place
several of us old-timers had a little
group actually we called ourselves the
caucus Ukraine
caucus and our headquarters were in the
monocle and we met and one of them was
matzo cells because she worked for the
National Science Foundation she was
detailed to senator Hollings so guess
who sponsored the resolution on the
famine in the Senate was senator
Hollings so that was the the beginning
of this campaign to officially recognize
and there were some interesting things
that happened we tried to get a hearing
on the Senate side and senator lugar
chairman of the Foreign Relations didn't
want to do it so we went to see senator
Jesse Helms now old-timers will remember
him as being quite the the rebel you
could say and he was chair of the
Agriculture Committee and so he claimed
that he had jurisdiction over this topic
because the whole Tamar had to do with
collectivization and the other in
agriculture so this sort of interesting
little thing but so this was the
beginning of pressing for recognition
and I besides thanking the Atlantic
Council for organizing this event I want
to thank the the people who put together
this film because I think this film
represents a milestone in the world
recognizing this event when you have in
events like this now being introduced
into the popular culture be it film or
books I think this is another as a step
towards more widely people recognizing
and accepting the historical fact of
this now in the when we were doing this
resolution we thought we were uncovering
as sort of the world for the Congress
let me back this year we are actually
celebrating 100 years of Congress
supporting the people of Ukraine one of
the things we discovered was that
actually in 1934 Hamilton fished the 3rd
of New York
introduced a resolution in regards to
the family so the world knew people knew
and even in Washington people do now we
had the pleasure of interviewing him he
was already in his mid 90s and he ranted
and raved about President Roosevelt
because at that time that was the time
when we in the United States wanted to
recognize Russia so geopolitics
got in the way of the Congress being
able to officially recognize what was
taking place does anybody see parallels
to today so actually if we look at the
history Congress has been always in the
forefront on these kind of issues in
relations to Ukraine and throughout
history there have been different
reasons why presidents may not have
wanted to support or endorse certain
positions so it seems like history
continues now it's it's already been
somewhat discussed about the
disinformation I'm going to call it the
Kremlin playbook which is consistent
from then till now the only thing that
changes are the methods because of
advances in technology and resources and
I divide it into what people have
already said first it's the deny and
cover up whether was the hold Ahmad
whether it was Chernobyl well there was
the Millennium of Christianity you name
it that's the first step and then you
have the propaganda which provides an
alternative narrative to substitute for
the truth
and then we have fake news and the
biggest example of that was Walter
Durant II I think this is an interesting
case study about his role that he played
it was much more than just writing
articles to cover up what was going on
he was an integral part of promoting the
Soviet position looking him looking at
Walter durante I there was an
interesting quote since everybody's
quoting in November of 33 after there
had been some scented negotiations about
the recognition of Russia there was a
dinner at the Waldorf Astoria hosted by
the Soviet foreign minister and one of
the participants who wrote about that
said during the dinner as people were
being introduced there was mild applause
but when Walter durante was introduced
it was thunderous applause and this is
the quote one quite got the impression
that America in a spasm of discernment
was recognizing both Russia and Walter
Durante now the other part of the
playbook is to identify people of
stature and and recognize status who are
either paid experts or styling to find
them useful idiots and sometimes it's
hard to figure out where in which
category it I went to the Ukrainian
Weekly archives of for 1983 and I pulled
out an article not about to hold them on
but actually about Reverend Graham
attending a peace conference in Moscow
in nineteen
eighty-three the reason I pulled it out
because can you think of another person
who is so respected an American icon
than Reverend Graham spiritual advisor
to many presidents respected by people
of all faiths I mean I don't think
there's anybody who would attack
Reverend Graham so when he goes to
Moscow and says he sees no signs of
religious persecution despite the fact
that he visited with six pentacle
Pentecostal believers from Siberia who
had been living in the u.s. embassy for
five years he then went on to say things
like he went to several Orthodox
churches and they were packed something
that he would not see in Charlotte North
Carolina his home and the final one
which was really check hard to read when
talking about food shortages he said I
had wonderful meals caviar in America
only the very rich can afford caviar why
I'm not picking on Reverend Brown but I
am trying to illustrate that when you
have someone of this stature who for
whatever reason is promoting a certain
line now this was a prelude to 1988 when
we were commemorating the Millennium of
Christianity I happen to be the chair of
the government relations for that and it
was political guerilla warfare because
the Kremlin was trying to seize it as
the millennium of Christianity in Russia
so it's very challenging to maneuver
through today in terms of different
people I'm not going to name names who
are in this category the final step is
to vilify
and attack those who speak the truth and
it's been already brought up Garrett
Jones was a Welsh journalist who bravely
was undercover in Ukraine he spoke to
like language and he held a press
conference in 1933 talking about the
famine he was denounced attacked and
just two years later he was murdered
under suspicious circumstances so
unfortunately I don't think we see much
changes in the situation both in the
playbook
by the Kremlin or unfortunately maybe
sometimes in terms of politics here in
Washington thank you
John if a may ask a very broad and
sweeping question why is it so important
today to understand the events of 1932
and 1933 oh let me give seven main
points to answer you're totally
unscripted question one it's important
to understand that the horrors of the
communist regime were world class
Horrors among the worst things in human
experience and that the people
brutalized under communist rule were all
the peoples of the Soviet Union not to
mention the peoples of China and
Cambodia Kampuchea and so on I mention
that because right now we're talking
about one specific perhaps the most
terrific of all the communist crimes
well maybe I'd say you could say what
happened in China during the Cultural
Revolution you could talk about the
family in China in 1961 you're talking
about what happened in Kampuchea or
Cambodia after the Communists came to
power as comparable but everyone
suffered including the Russians point to
that's point two or three Putin's Russia
and this is something we've been talking
about since the panel began is a serious
geopolitical problem and a serious human
rights problem but not nearly on the
same magnitude as the Soviet Union in
either category 0.3 in that period of
not quite a decade of possible Russian
democracy that followed the fall or the
implosion of the Soviet Union there was
real interest in Russia in the horrors
of communism the KGB archives were
opened serious research was done and we
are grateful for the findings of that
research
you also had a civic organization in
Russia that appeared in the 80s in the
last days of the Soviet Union Tom it's
run by the eminent academician likhachev
that was interested and Tom it means
memorial which is interested in
memorializing the sufferings sufferings
under communism 0.4 sadly this brief
Russian flirtation with democracy ended
when you had the hand off from President
Yeltsin to then Prime Minister Putin who
became President Putin and mr. Putin was
and is a KGB agent he says you never
leave the service except with extreme
prejudice of course and Putin famously
said that the great geopolitical tragedy
of the 20th century was not the
Holocaust
nakta Holodomor but the fall of the
Soviet Union which of course is a great
misjudgments in moral terms and mr.
Putin represented the seal or Viki the
people who ran the KGB the Ministry of
Defense and various other than the
of interior the power ministries of the
Soviet Union and his becoming president
meant the return of this psychological
type to power in Russia and that
psychological type greatly enjoyed the
geopolitical preeminence of the Soviet
Union and to this day they feel for that
preeminence the way a person whose leg
is amputated feels they're vanished leg
it's no surprise therefore this is 0.5
that under this regime of Salovey key of
former KGB and KGB mod K types there is
no interest in looking at the horrors of
communism in fact the ideologue to
extent that Putin is an ideologist and I
say to the extent because I don't want
to overstate this his contribution if
you want to use that now is to creating
a fusion of Czarist greatness and Soviet
greatness which is a legacy which the
Russian people today have as a point of
navigation as they look to the future
and that legacy concludes those of the
aspects discussed by my fellow panelists
0.6 so what is the importance of the
Holodomor 1 it's really important in
ukrainian national consciousness for the
people of ukraine to understand what was
done to them as a horror of communism
but also in order to quash ukrainian
national feeling at a critical moment in
soviet history is important to
understand ukraine as independent
country just as Putin's aggression in
Ukraine has solidified a national
consciousness to hollowed amor was an
earlier preconscious recognition kiss me
of a phenomenon of the same kind to say
preconscious because only it's Ukrainian
intellectuals understood it in the 30s
so that's reason what but reasons - this
comes more to what I've already said it
is a wedge for understanding more
broadly the horrors of communism not
just in Ukraine but also in Russia in
China and so on in that respect this
film bitter harvest could wind up being
a very important cultural event that's
certainly my hope does this leads to a
serious conversation about the things
that happened in the Soviet Union and
I'm surprised and on the
I'm glad I'm delighted to be the free
safety on this panel because I'm
surprised that no one mentioned the
actual extent of the horrors of the
hollow the more if you look at the
various writings on it the number of
fatalities ranges from a low three
million to high of 10 or even 11 million
very large number a very large number
finally the Holodomor
and recognition of the extent of the
horrors the recognition of who was
responsible and who was responsible
Politburo of the Soviet Union is an
important geopolitical fact today and a
geopolitical fact of prime importance to
the Kremlin for two reasons reason one
they understand that a true under -
recognition of this horror makes it hard
for them to ignore the problems of
communism how can they speak positively
about this about this past of theirs if
everyone understands that separately in
or as many as ten or eleven million
people were starved to death by
conscious policy therefore they have
attacked Ukraine's commemoration of the
Holodomor
as an example of extreme Ukrainian
nationalism and moosa' phobic tendencies
which is nonsense point two on this was
second point of point seven sorry about
that
point B is that this commemoration is
also a danger to putin's authoritarian
project in russia because again the same
regime that nuked Litvinov the same
regime that murdered Politkovskaya that
murdered me m self
the regime does not want to acknowledge
the horrors on an absolutely
extraordinary scale of the Communist
period and that is ultimately the
significance of talking about the
Holodomor and this film I think I've
said enough
no it's excellent thank you thank you
for your remarks we have about a little
less than 15 minutes left and so I'd
like to ask one more round of questions
and if you could keep your remarks to
about two or three minutes before we
open it up to the audience
Michael if I could go back to you and
you touched on this a little bit but but
looking at sort of present day looking
at the disinformation campaign coming
out of Moscow how does that affect
events in Ukraine and I'm talking about
the illegal annexation of Crimea and the
war in Donbass great question I think
actually John answered a bit of it in
terms of looking at it from the national
consciousness of the Ukrainians and and
and frankly speaking it's it's a
narrative it's something that's coming
out of the Kremlin that in terms of this
fake news in terms of a narrative and
how the world is supposed to believe
this narrative but obviously it's a
matter of the self conscious self
consciousness of the Ukrainians and it
is harboring now ideas of we as
Ukrainians need to stand up for
ourselves because the world frankly
speaking is not the same as it was 85
years ago there are different tactics
that are being used in terms of this
information luckily enough the world is
open enough to new technologies in terms
of social media and and so forth that we
can actually know some of the truths
that are happening right now in Ukraine
and with that 85 years ago unfortunately
other than a few journalists the world
did not know but how do you combat that
there are so many new methods
methodologies that you can combat
today's present crisis in Ukraine
obviously in terms of the little green
men in Crimea that already we knew as a
fact that was out there it needs
unfortunately I think what is necessary
is
something that happened even 85 years
ago though the information was known 85
years ago it was a matter at times of
appeasement and I'll give you a quote as
well well going off I have something
ready there was a document compiled by
the British Foreign Service and in this
particular document it says the truth of
the matter is of course that we have a
certain amount of information about
famine conditions in Ukraine we do not
want to make it public however because
of the Soviet government the Soviet
government would resent it and our
relations with them would be prejudiced
so that makes I think a complete psycho
and a complete circle here that it's a
matter of appeasement and we don't want
to appease we cannot appease right now
and that I think is is in terms of an
answer to your question it solidifies
the Ukrainians and what they are trying
to accomplish what they are trying to do
integrate into Europe they've been a
democracy before this is not the first
time the Ukraine has had a democratic
republic in a democratic country but
it's civil society which makes the
difference frankly speaking that's one
of the things that Stalin wanted to
annihilate as much as possible is that
free will and that free thinking from
the Ukrainians because he needed
obviously their land for for his
collectivization and for his
industrialization and he needed to
squelch the population today the
population won't be squelched but
unfortunately if there's matters of
appeasement on larger global political
scales then the Ukrainians obviously
feel that they could be back 85 years
ago thank you enough Ptolemy it's this
has been hit on a little bit but sure
but but examples of accurate portrayals
of what's going on and in that part of
the world about Russian aggression you
talked about textbooks and culture can
you talk more about that and the the
memorial that was constructed a couple
of years ago can you talk more about the
positive developments taking place mmm
sure so the memorial Michael can
definitely
talk about a bit more than I can I guess
where I want to go with this is that
there has definitely been examples of
good cultural memory in the post-soviet
space that can be followed in Latvia for
example one of the first things that
they did in Riga after Latvia became
independent again was they changed all
the street names in the city people were
asking the mayor at the time you know
what why are you focusing on street
names when people need to adapt to an
entire new type of lifestyle and people
need to eat and his response was public
symbols matter your public references
and your cultural sphere matters in the
way that you perceive the world and
digest information so so that is why the
memorial here in DC and matters and is a
good step in the right direction that's
why the film matters as much as I hope
that this panel is seen by a lot of
people I think the films going to be
seen by a lot more that is a step in the
right direction
in Russia that step hasn't been taken if
you walk through the street in Moscow
you see hammers and sickles all over the
metro stations
whereas in post-soviet and Warsaw Pact
capitals the giant monstrous statues of
Stalin have been torn down they they've
been torn down but actually just moved
to a park in Moscow you can still you
can still go and see them and of course
textbooks haven't changed the way that
schoolchildren commemorate their own
history is unapologetic even proud
Ukraine on this cultural sphere is a
country in flux
they have been democratic and they've
been working tirelessly since the
collapse of the Soviet Union but it's
not always easy people don't want to you
know tear down the statue of Lenin where
they celebrated their 13th birthday 50
years
go it's hard to to change the smaller
villages the the textbooks but that's
where the fight has to happen thanks
Nadia you you made the point of the the
Russian playbook being the same over the
decades and generations how maybe the
tools have changed how might one or have
my organization's or the international
community combat this what programs
could be done how do we raise awareness
well I think it's just constant
vigilance I mean I think you hear in the
Atlantic Council have done I think a
fantastic job of putting out you know
credible information Jim if I might make
some other comments that one of the
things I don't think we have come to
understand is the impacts of the whole
damar on ukraine society as such and I
think it's something worthy of maybe
analysis as well and I'm just going to
cite three examples ambassadors to
debauch
dr. Shabak when he was here one time in
his speech he talked about the fear that
still remains within Ukraine because of
the whole of the mall and this whole so
when you think about that this fear is
still incarcerated in society I think it
makes the recent striving of society
that much more remarkable I'm also going
to give you a couple of examples in 1992
I happen to be in Ukraine with a
colleague of mine and we went to visit
her elderly aunt and of course we're all
you for because Ukraine is independent
and then she tells me that her aunt is
squirreling away dry bread
the notion that Ukraine's independence
somehow may threaten them because that's
what cultivation was all about there's
another documentary film that I'd
recommend the bhavish Kiev turn oval
that it's done by an American woman it's
strangely uplifting but it's about these
women in their 80s and 90s who've gone
back to the Chernobyl zone and of course
a lot is made about the fact that
they're living with radiation and there
are people coming out you know testing
them and their water and all of that but
in the film one of them says they have
no fear about the radiation the thing
that they fear is famine not having
enough food to eat so this is I think
has is really has seeped into society in
ways that we have not really I think yet
come to understand and on this point you
know we could talk about the
disinformation by the Kremlin I have to
I think bring out the fact that the
Party of Regions and President
Yanukovych was not ready to recognize
this horrific event even though the most
harshest of this whole Tamar was
suffered in eastern Ukraine so I think
this is something that is it was to me
of interest you know in 2008 when
President Yushchenko was doing a major
program to recognize the whole Tamar
there was a lot of criticism I was at a
forum in Romania and some European said
oh he's wasting his time he shouldn't be
focusing on the whole of the mark there
are more important things to focus on
and I contradicted to him because I
happen to be there and one of the things
I observed was people in eastern Ukraine
who had lived through the hall tomorrow
and had never spoken about it were
finally feeling free to talk about it so
can you imagine the impact of keeping
this inside the fear and the terror and
what that has has done to I think the
Ukrainian society and so I think again
the fact of what we're seeing in
Ukraine's a fight for its own
independence and democracy is that much
more remarkable given the fact that they
have this remembrance of terror hmm
thank you John we just have a couple of
minutes do you have any other remarks
you'd like sort of in response to what
the panelists said oh no I have a
reading assignment for the audience if
you want to know about the Holodomor
probably the book to read is bitter
harvest there should be harvest of
sorrow by Robert conquest the great
British historian there's another author
you should read whose books I can't
remember his name is James Mays who's
written extensively about about the
Holodomor and finally everyone was
speaking about the concept of useful
idiots Westerners who were doing the
Soviet bidding even if they didn't
understand it a person to read on this
subject to get n remember the name of
the book is Paul Hollander Holland with
an ER great book with that I'm doing
thank you
we'd love to open it up for questions
from the audience and if you could
please identify yourself and give your
affiliation yes sir
wait a mic thank you so much mr.
Fairbanks for organizing this wonderful
panel my name is David Talbott I work at
the victims of communism Memorial
Foundation and I would like to offer it
to you as moderator to defer the
question where you see it best answered
one of the things in thinking about the
future of Ukraine that didn't
necessarily come up in the conversation
today is the future of Ukraine in the
context of the new administration and I
would love to hear thoughts about how
people who love Ukraine are thinking and
strategizing right now
for the welfare of their people well
thanks thanks Davey interesting question
obviously and I had a feeling that this
would would would come up you know I
think you have to put everything in
perspective and given given if we're
discussing the whole of the modern and
and the events of 85 years ago and the
world not knowing and the quote that I
had written that I had mentioned about
the the British Foreign Service
diplomats talking about they knew about
it yet they didn't say anything about it
meaning appeasement well we know what
appeasement has led to we know what
appeasement led to a 1933 1933 thank
actually in 1933 the United States
recognized the Soviet Union as an entity
during the height of of the famine we
know what happened in the late 1930s
because of appeasement and what that led
to so I'm looking at this as a global
context and perspective of the the issue
of appeasement for whose sake we have to
know that the facts are out there we
have to know what builds a strong world
and that is democracy democratic
principles of free and open society and
there is a fight going on right now not
in some obscure part of the world not in
some small little plot of land this is
in the center of Europe at the heart of
Europe's principles is exactly a fight
for freedom that is happening and if we
in the West in particular the United
States don't realize that for exactly
what it is that I'm fearful that that
appeasement may lead to other
unfortunate aspects in the future thank
you John do you eject respond oh let me
answer not so much as someone who loves
Ukraine but as someone who has some
affection from Ukraine but also not some
affection for for
but most importantly a lot of affection
for the United States all right we have
a serious geopolitical problem and the
leader of the world's second most
powerful military the other one of the
two great nuclear superpowers has a
religious agenda in Europe once the
weakened NATO wants to weaken
transatlantic ties once I have a sphere
of influence in his neighborhood Jim
mattis is correct to say this is the
most important danger we face today we
need a policy that recognizes that just
about everyone chosen by President Trump
to a senior national security position
seems to understand that the new
National Security Adviser seems to get
it Secretary of State seems to get it
this director of the CIA seems to get it
the vice president seems to get it it's
not so clear that the president the
United States seems to get it that is
worrying having said that we've seen in
the wake of an inclination on the part
of our commander in chief to offer
preemptive concessions to the Kremlin
resistance coming from within his
administration and from Congress we've
seen this cop this opera beef with this
Ukrainian piece this quote-unquote
Ukrainian peace plan as reported by the
New York Times all this is making people
here wonder what is up and I believe as
a result of this we will ultimately see
a sound policy recognizing the dangers
of putin's wishes and the need to make
putin pay a price for his aggression in
Ukraine by supporting Ukrainian people
as they deserve to be supported
especially since they gave up the
nuclear weapons in response to
assurances from the United States and
Britain and France and China
not to mention Russia and the Russian
cash okay Naftali first CEO jumped in oh
sorry I have two things that I think
everyone in this room could do to help
Ukraine in the next week the next month
concrete things one educate our own
American kids about the real history of
Ukraine make sure they are completely
inoculated a
and whatever you want to call it fake
news fake facts
it's just incorrect things educate them
and to is assist Ukrainian civil society
trained their journalists fund their
schools support their democratic
movements and then Ukraine will make an
educated choice for itself I would say
that we need to have more Americans
understand that Ukraine people of
Ukraine are in the front lines not only
does for their independence and
sovereignty but really defending
euro-atlantic values as somebody said
unlike Vegas what happens in Ukraine
doesn't just stay in Ukraine and if you
look at what Putin is doing all over
whether it's at the in the Arctic
whether it's working in in Europe
so this is not an isolated Ukraine is
not an isolated case but Ukraine is on
the frontlines literally militarily and
Ukraine is succeeding and it can succeed
if we honor our commitments of the
Budapest memorandum and given the tools
militarily to ultimately succeed so they
are fighting our fight and that's I
think the message that we need to I
think more broadly understand within our
own country thank you another question
yes sir
one difference oh sorry one difference
between 85 years ago and today is the
role and presence of the russian
orthodox church and the russian orthodox
church maastricht moscow patriarchate
has been supporting the separatist
movement in in Donbass I believe they're
also a major conduit for Russian
disinformation into Ukraine I was
wondering if anybody is wants to comment
on what you see going on in Ukraine
today what what seems to amount to a war
within a war between the Moscow
Patriarchate the Kiev Patriarchate and
the Ukraine Catholic Church thank you
thank you there's no question that the
Moscow Patriarchate remains an
instruments of Kremlin foreign policy
including in Ukraine there's also a
little doubt that the Russian Orthodox
Church Moscow Patriarchate was used by
the Kremlin during the Orange Revolution
as a result of which it lost a
substantial number of supporters
believers in Ukraine who switch to the
Kiev patriarch aid and to a lesser
extent to the autonomous Orthodox Church
of Ukraine this this circumstance also
worsened in the current round the
current crisis between Russia and
Ukraine the previous metropolitan of the
Moscow Patriarchate Valle Lord the MIR
and Kiev understood what happened during
the Orange Revolution and he tried to
mitigate MP support for the Kremlin at
the start of the crisis in the winter of
1314 he's since passed the scene and by
and large the MP reverted to type all
this has led to a strengthening of the
position of the kr Patriarchate and to a
much lesser extent of the autonomous
Orthodox Church of Ukraine the Muny a
church doesn't really play in this they
remain strongly supportive of the
Ukrainian national project but by and
large you haven't seen Orthodox
in Ukraine moving to the Uniate Church
as a result of the MPs not very pretty
game in country and well by the way one
last point when you've had a period of
hierarchs of the Kiev branch of the
Moscow Patriarchate pushing back against
their leadership in Moscow that's led to
some tensions within the MP between
Russia and Ukraine can I add something
yes
one of the things I'd like to add to
this and and and John is correct
obviously in terms of speaking about the
actual role of the churches but there's
a little bit more that I'd like to
mention in terms of I'm sure that you've
heard of this term leukemia Russian
world this is the the the opportunity of
Russia to use as again as a branch of
its foreign policy arm to protect
quote-unquote those russian-speaking
citizens speaking the russian-speaking
population in the near abroad as they
call it
so Ukraine is an example of that the
Baltic states the caucuses and so forth
and so on this is a conscious effort
that is being used by the Kremlin and by
Moscow on how to stifle resistance as
much as possible and they use the church
in that capacity as well so the church
here is not any type of the Russian
Orthodox Church Moscow Patriarchate is
not necessarily an altruistic type of
Church here they're not out there for
your soul frankly speaking they are out
there frankly part and parcel with the
with the the foreign policy arm of the
Kremlin and we must understand that that
this is being this this notion of
warfare in Ukraine as as we have alluded
to that Ukraine is literally on the
front lines but it's not just militarily
whether we can go to Congress and go to
the administration and ask for weaponry
for for Ukraine it's not just about the
military aspect here there's an
informational hybrid war that that's
going on as well and then Saru scheme it
is exactly that hybrid warfare but it
has different facets to it it has facets
of cultural and has facets of religious
has fascist facets of social you look
back in the nineteen nineteen 30s not
just
the more times but even right after who
are some of the first people that Stalin
sent to prisons the intelligentsia the
priests the priests the bishops those
that actually led civil society those
that had trust within civil society
Stalin knew that in the 1930s 40s and
50s Putin knows that today please yes
underscore was John said the Russian
Orthodox Church has always been and
continues to be an arm of the state and
we see that plane continuing to play out
for instance even in terms of some of
the politics with the Vatican but I
think there's a the Council of the all
Ukrainian churches and religious
organizations in Ukraine is a powerful
anecdote to this it unites all the
Protestant churches the Muslim faiths
the Jewish faiths the Orthodox and the
Catholic and they are a real active
force and body and so I think they are a
enormous resource and weapon - I think
counterbalance what's being done by the
Russian Orthodox Church no fella I think
it's important to note here that the the
problem is not the Russian Orthodox
Church as such but the Russian regime's
co-opting of the Russian Orthodox Church
the the Catholic Church in Poland for
example was an incredible force for good
and bringing down communism specifically
because polish identity was so wrapped
up with with the Catholic Church that
was a very important component but why
is the Russian Orthodox Church so
successful or the Russian regime so
successful in co-opting the Russian
Orthodox Church I think that's something
that needs a little bit more exploration
when the KGB archives were open for a
brief time in the 90s it became
tragically clear that most of the
Russian Orthodox priests were reporting
what they heard him confessional to the
KGB
a tremendous breach of ecumenical and
personal trust and another interesting
point is that most Russians
despite communism is nominal atheism and
today identify as as Orthodox it's a
part of their identity more so even than
necessarily a part of their faith and
the Russian regime is very successful on
playing this up almost in some new
segments harkening back to the old
Tsar's Trinity of Orthodoxy orthodoxy
autocracy and nationhood as the pillars
of what they call Russian civilization
so the Russian regime is successful in
this because they play on very old
identities and and beliefs and what
needs to be done is to uncouple that the
real people of faith in the Russian
church have to take their church back
thank you and I think you have the next
question can we get a microphone over
here
Alain's Saraya associate rector of wi uu
in kiev ukraine
I'd like to tithe so all these points to
me together starting with Michael when
your first statement was the French
quote in the 80 1800s and basically what
we're seeing about how facts are
manipulated to a particular end to their
to their win and all the way right now
to what we're experiencing at this very
moment we'll all walk out check the news
and we're going to see some more of the
fake news the manipulation of the news
the propaganda everything that is being
cranked out is becoming more and more
difficult to know what's coming forward
that's clear and accurate versus what's
tainted and so on that being said what
we're dealing with today is a very
complex situation it's it's Ukraine it's
what's happened to Ukraine
it's the documentation which will of
Holliman hall tomorrow which will brings
past history to light and factually and
now we're facing the effects of Russia's
aggression in Ukraine being practiced to
the extent that has been able to be
exported here in our society in a
different way again through information
manipulation cyber secure cyber issues
so how would you like to respond to how
we're going to be able to aggressively
bring this forward to the American
public to understand how important this
is in Ukraine because Ukraine is us
thank you
Michael do you want to start with you
and we'll work our way down sure thank
you for the question it's it's a complex
answer I don't think there's a an easy
fix to any of this I'd like to begin in
terms of some of the things that have
happened already some positive things
that have happened already and
how we as an American society can can
build upon that last year within a
National Defense Authorization Act there
was a the the bill there was an
amendment which added eighty million
dollars for the formation of a center
which would gather information this was
this is to be within the State
Department to gather information this is
the Portman Murphy dis Information Act
to gather information about the
disinformation that is coming from
Russia and to use that and to to
leverage all of that disinformation
that's coming and come up with the true
narrative as compared to obviously
Putin's narrative and so forth the issue
is not so much even here in the United
States of distributing that true
narrative frankly speaking it's going
back to Ukraine or going back to the
quote-unquote near abroad and
distributing that information back there
that I think is one of the first keys to
our success is that it has to start on a
local civil society type basis in
Ukraine if they get the information from
us on how to combat that information
working together in unison with other
Western democracies I think that's one
of the first bugs that we can that we
need to build upon a second aspect is
obviously even here what some of my
colleagues on the panel have alluded to
we need to get the truth out there as
much as possible meaning it needs to
start within curriculum in in in our
high schools not just about Holodomor
but but about everything in general
there's a geostrategic context to all of
this
this again is not just about Ukraine
we're discussing the issue is 85 years
ago of Holdem or and how that relates to
right now but again what happened 85
years ago and and what is happening now
what is happening now we can actually do
something about it and the the bringing
this to to American society having more
discussions such as this I think is
uniquely an opportune way to bring forth
a little bit more of that
combating that narrative that
disinformation it's it's it's much more
difficult sometimes now unfortunately to
deal with this because what's happening
in terms of this ruski Mir which I had
mentioned earlier it's weaponizing
information it's a very hard concept to
understand weaponizing information you
think of information as facts and you
build your case upon those facts but
it's actually weaponizing it it's making
it into its own beast so to say and I
think that's where our our work lies
ahead of us let's begin in these small
steps let's begin with with civil
society in the greater European venue
and theatre and then obviously we need
to do in parallel we need to do the same
thing here in the United States
education like Michael mentioned is is
the key and if I could be so bold as to
add to your reading list that's already
very useful one of my favorite books on
communism is witnessed by Whittaker
Chambers in the introduction to the book
where Chambers is sitting in his
farmhouse in New Jersey writing the
letter to his children he writes a line
that I always remember he goes I want to
inoculate you against communism before
you ever learn the word it's it's a
belief in truth as an antidote to
untruth learning the truth before you
ever even learn the untruth
so let's amend that for for 2017 let's
inoculate our children against Russian
disinformation before they ever even
learned the term
well as everybody has noted this is an
enormous Lee complex situation because
the amount of resources that the Kremlin
has devoted to this disinformation is
enormous
and I don't think we need to necessarily
match dollar-for-dollar
their resources but I do think that we
need to be strategic about it and well I
have some hope for whatever program
could be developed within the government
to address this issue I'm not sure that
that's the total answer because we know
a government bureaucracy which will be
created to coordinate messaging will not
be nimble and it cannot be nimble and
quick and quick I think it has a role at
a conference last week that actually
Michaels organization sponsored one of
the people was from the IT world in
Ukraine and he mentioned that they had
some volunteers who are working on this
issue I mean most of it is happening in
social media so I would like to
challenge the Ukrainians who have proven
themselves in this IT world being
cutting-edge to take this initiative and
somehow create a program that will bring
in the volunteers that they have and to
be strategic about it it has to be
fought on many many fronts each of us
with our respective organizations can
play a role but I think it requires also
a massive approach particularly in the
social media world John Lopez okay we
have about 10 minutes left which might
give us time for two questions and short
responses it was Sir in the back
Bob McConnell I'd like to make a comment
following up on something mrs. McConnell
just said she challenged Ukrainian IT
specialist I'd like to challenge the
Ukrainian government they are
incompetent in sending their own message
they're still talking not about a war
Russia's war with Ukraine but by an but
they talk about an anti-terrorist
operation it's about time they said what
was going on in true terms thank you
another question or comment yes ma'am
hello my name is Rock Solano Inara
and I have been working with a nonprofit
called the cranes of Colorado providing
humanitarian assistance to victims of
the war in eastern Ukraine and I just
recently moved here from Colorado and I
just would like to I'm also an aspiring
scholar on Ukrainian issues and
particularly hold more and I'd like to
thank you so much for hosting this panel
it's very important for people to
realize the importance and kind of going
off of what we've heard today I would
just like for you to please speak about
what has been done here in the US and
also what you think should be done as
far as trying to get holding more on the
level of not only recognition as the
Holocaust which Ukraine's also suffered
in as well as of course Jews and but
also too as the Holocaust has been you
know in in several countries in Europe I
think it's about 13 countries there's
been a ban to deny you know that you
can't deny the Holocaust and I'm and
also with that the symbolism of Nazism
for example like the salute to Hitler
and so forth
as we've seen recently the communist
symbols of the hammer and sickle have
been particularly popular with Hollywood
I believe it was Kim Kardashian who
recently appeared wearing a sweatshirt
wearing the hammer and sickle and for
many people that was very offensive so I
was just wondering since Holda Mars and
the epitome of the great evil of
communism that has happened particularly
in Ukraine several other genocides and
famines that happen in Ukraine that
aren't as well researched as a Holdem or
for example but I would like to know
what you think can be done and what has
been done to try and put a holding more
on that level to you know been the
denial of it thank you thank you anyone
would like to take that a short quick
response very nice question thank you
very much frankly speaking a lot has
been done it may not be evident as much
but I I think this is where the rest of
us in terms of American society we have
to roll up our shirt sleeves and get to
work a little bit I'll give you some
examples of what has happened and
obviously what is still necessary
worldwide they're only 14 countries that
have acknowledged they hold the more as
a genocide so that's one of the first
things that needs to be done it need
this needs to be brought more to the
world's attention
there are many Ukrainian diasporas
throughout various parts of the world it
is our role as a diaspora to to bring
forth this notion of recognizing the
whole DeMott as a genocide so I think
that that that remains first and
foremost and while the United States did
have a commission on the Ukraine famine
as it was called back in 1988 or 86
excuse me and it did mention that we in
terms of this commission find that it
was a genocide that's down committed
genocide in 1932-33 the US government as
a whole has not recognized it as of yet
however interestingly enough if you go
to the legislation which enacted the
construction and the and the building of
the memorial hold the Memorial in
Washington DC it actually does state
that it is holding water slash gently
the Ukrainian famine slash genocide of
1932-33 so certain things have been done
regarding curriculum again what what
Naphtali had mentioned earlier it's all
about education and this is not a
centralized way in the United States are
not a centralized educational system so
this all begins from local grassroots
and and and goes further up so it's
necessary for you to get out there as
much as possible within your school
boards within your respective states to
get this done the state of Illinois is
mandatory that you have to learn about
the whole D'Amato in social studies
classes Massachusetts is fighting that
battle right now New York State as a
matter of fact
the regents exam two years ago actually
had a question on European history about
hold Ahmad and you get to choose do you
answer that or do you answer another
aspect about World War two another
question regarding World War two so
there are certain things that are that
are out there I can give you a great
example Senator Schumer when he appears
at our newly commemorations of Hold'em
or at st. Patrick's Cathedral he always
mentions that this is the Ukrainian
Holocaust so the more that this
information gets out there the more that
it it basically gives us and riches up
and gives us the fortitude to move
forward thank you please I want to get
everyone a chance to have closing
remarks few minutes left I'll give you
two concrete examples about education
programs that we're doing we have a high
school program as in victims of
communism oil foundation that brings
high school teachers into Washington DC
trains them on curricula and then sends
them back out to their high schools to
talk to their students we also do
college programs where we bring speakers
like us and films to campus and film is
the most important component I think the
film the trailer that we just saw the
words holida more was a genocide are big
intimidating words that not everybody
can easily access but if you make a film
about how Russian troops coming over the
border to confiscate grain during a time
of a famine kept the handsome
protagonist from his beautiful fiancee
now we're getting somewhere
yes I would underscore that because you
can't get everybody to you know read a
history book or sit down for a really a
history listen but begin to spoon-feed
and I think promote it I haven't seen
the film but I think what's been said
about it I think it's an excellent way
to introduce this topic and to maybe get
people interested so I would just urge
once it's out of the theaters to maybe
use it in various settings in schools or
organizations again to it's sort of the
soft touch
and since people have been promoting
books I'm gonna promote one it's fiction
it's called child 44 it's a murder
mystery it's a pain you can't put it
down
it is spell and it is set at the time of
the whole of the mall so again it's an
easy way to introduce don't the film is
not nearly as good as the book but it's
an easy way again to get people to be
introduced to the topic in in in
different ways I'm gonna make a comment
to mr. McConnell's comment there's been
frustration because a lot of the
information coming from the Ukrainian
government most of the time it's been in
Ukrainian but I have noted in the last
several weeks that there have been some
very interesting infographics because I
think that's what's needed you know
whether you're trying to go to you know
Congress or whatever everybody wants it
on a you know one page they're not going
to read you know multiple reports so we
could spoon-feed this various kinds of
information I think that would be
helpful so hopefully they'll be more
coming out from the Ukrainian government
John we have about two minutes if you
want to give any thoughts a responsive
later I think the the last question
points to a problem which again is
there's no clear understanding in
society as a whole of the horrors of the
communist project for that reason you
see symbols you see communist symbols
you see the continuing glorification of
that folk Che Guevara you need to change
the culture in order for people to
understand that this use of symbols from
this absolutely historically
unprecedented bloody project is
unacceptable we are in a pre
consciousness phase right now I try to
be a realist so I can't say I see us
reaching this position as a society in
the near or even the mid term but I
think over time it can happen and I'm
hoping that this film bitter harvest
will be an initial breakthrough
thank you and with that I just want to
thank the panelists if you join me with
a round of applause thank you for coming
today I believe there's a reception
after this thank you very much
and go see the movie bitter harvest
please